now enough about them let's talk about
me for a minute
that's that's why you really tuned in to
see me talk about me
um let me bring you up to date i've been
spending a lot of time i know i'm out
here and i'm telling jokes every night i
look like a happy guy
but true story lately i've been spending
a lot of time thinking about my life
you know examining who am i who is conan
o'brien
uh what makes him so amazing and uh
i decided to uh search for enlightenment
i did you know you hear about people
trying to find enlightenment i decided i
would search for enlightenment so
i visited best-selling author doctor and
spiritual advisor deepak chopra
yeah he's not far from our building he
actually has something called the chopra
center in midtown manhattan which is
just a couple of blocks from here
i decided to go to the chopra center
and try and find enlightenment from
deepak chopra and whenever i search for
enlightenment i always bring a camera
crew and try and put it on television
i did uh just that i brought a crew and
uh here's what happened
good to see you how are you my pleasure
thanks for seeing me
you have a second i'd like to shine sure
absolutely
i think you know i wanted to come here
because
i'm probably uh crying out for help in
some ways
so what do you think is the problem
uh i'm not very centered i don't think
i'm a centered person
i don't know if you're getting an energy
off of me or not i am getting an energy
of you but
i think it might be part of the reason
you are so successful
that energy you're desperate to be liked
you're
insecure you have a lot of anger
inside you you have a little bit of rage
that goes back
to some childhood trauma i think i'd
love to speak to your mother
oh my god you have a desperate need to
be right
you engage in one apprenticeship and
you're very competitive
you can feel all that coming off sure
really yeah
now i might tell you by the way that
these are all risk factors for
premature death more than smoking
more than hypertension more than
diabetes it might be
very good for your ratings but it's not
good for your health
you've offered me an interesting choice
between
possible salvation or an early death
but good ratings and i honestly don't
know which one to take
would you like to uh get some tea and
discuss this further yeah if you wanted
to have a tea room is that correct sure
do you think it's possible uh for me to
still be funny but also enlightened can
you be enlightened and funny are
are great religious figures funny are
they funny peoples
i think jesus is a lot of fun to be
around or you know no
i'll be very honest with you i read the
new testament many times
jesus weeps but he never laughs he never
cracks a joke
didn't the apostle paul fall out of an
olive tree and jesus just lost it
he's like paul was after jesus's
crucifixion i tested you and you did
very well
i'm trying to test you that's my need to
always be right isn't he here
so can i ask you a few questions sure
why don't you close your eyes
who are you i'm conan o'brien
who are you who am i
uh i'm an all-knowing being
i'm popped by the sailor man
what do you want me spinach
what are your unique talents
i'm double jointed in my right arm
i have excellent hair
i have no pigment in my skin i can be
seen easily in the dark
i'm the ultimate dream for every woman
what do you look for in a good friend
inherited wealth a car that i can use on
the weekends
who are your heroes and heroines in
history and mythology and religion
abraham lincoln thor
spider-man the early comics he got
self-indulgent later on
hogan from hogan's heroes
what are the best qualities you display
in your relationships
i'm generous
i give people photographs of myself as
presents
even my wife okay open your eyes so you
know what i learned
from this you're a good guy
i am a pretty good guy yeah you're a
good person you're screwed up but you're
good
about and you can you can tell me on a
scale of one to ten you've seen some
doozies but what do you think
on the screwed up scale how bad one
today
yeah i think 8.3
or something like that 8.3 that's not
good
you know the nice part of it is you're
a really good person i think i am yeah
you're an egomaniac but
[Music]
[Laughter]
i laugh at things that are true
do you think there's a lot of my energy
is up here or you know it's all about
this
with me you know what i mean your hair
tells those stories yeah my hair is
beckoning you to flamboyant or trying to
be flamboyant anywhere
they're failing depends i mean
you know some people might buy into it
it's the roughest thing anyone's ever
said to me you believe in meditation
yeah i'm going to ask you to just repeat
two words i am
i am say it again i am
say it again i am say it again
i am now whisper it i am
your spirit now stop
moving your lips and your tongue and
just keep thinking it
of course other thoughts will intrude
you might become aware of sounds
or sensations whenever you remember just
go back to repeating
i am that's all what did you experience
at first i'm doing it and then i'm
hearing
the air conditioning system and then i'm
picturing bruce willis climbing through
the air conditioning system the movie
die hard
then i'm thinking about the movie die
hard and how the first one was the best
one
the other ones weren't as good then i
started thinking
why'd they have to make more ones after
the first one it was so good
okay so let me show you a few breathing
techniques
[Applause]
it's got a fancy name in sanskrit you
don't have to know the name
it's called ujjayi breathing but um it's
called in this country it's called an
obscene phone call
that's called that'll cool you down
practice the ojai breathing observe your
breath
you can do the bellows breath um
there are lots of things but you know i
don't you can't get a phd before you get
out of kindergarten
i'm in kindergarten right now
am i a good little boy so far you're
doing pretty good
it's screwed up though you keep saying
that
mother's fault or father's fault not
playing the victim huh
well i really would like one of them to
really just
just look into the camera and just go
after my mom or my dad
please see then what you're going to do
you're not taking responsibility right
it doesn't matter
it's my fault that i like your parents
no that's guilt
see oh i can't get it it's no one's
fault
i am who i am rely who you are now take
responsibility
and make a change my father
well this was very nice of you thank you
so much yeah really nice to meet you
pleasure
just before we left the building uh
deepak chopra offered me a massage
here at his center he even gave me this
robe which is pretty cool
even the uh sandals here are doing the
breathing exercise
look
i feel like robocop
i'm gonna go have my massage now
ladies just before we begin i'll just
give you the standard pre-massage
warning you're going to see some stuff
and hear some stuff a little off the
charts my apologies in advance
what's happening we're gonna do a slight
meditation
oh that's our aruba blend
it's a fragrance supposed to be relaxing
[Music]
hello okay whoa
that's great i wasn't this naked on my
wedding night
i kept the tuxedo on
you my favorite kind of massages deep
pot tissue
i don't know how i do it i honestly
don't know how i do it
we are now moving on to shiradara that's
right this is a
warm oil treatment look at this
contraption right here
this treatment consists of pouring a
warm herbalized oil over your forehead
mainly your third eye
now i know how a carb salad feels
well that's it we've reached the end of
the road
or the beginning or maybe there never
was a road
anywho i'd like to thank deepak chopra
and everyone at the chopra center for
telling me i'm incredibly screwed up
it's all my own fault
dunking my head in oil thanks
i am i am
i am
i am die hard sequels were
they just weren't as good damn why did
they make those
first one just stop after the first one
so much cooler
i am
you